[Musica]
uno dei primi ricordi della mia vita è
mia madre che piange in cucina
io e mio fratello più piccolo di me
andiamo a consolarla e le chiediamo
mamma cosa c'è e lei risponde niente
niente ma intanto continuava a stare
male e io capisco che quel niente
qualcosa che arriva all'improvviso le
porta via tutto
io un bambino allegro vivace di quei
bambinetti che si divertono con tutto
con tutti che giocano un bambino felice
ma cominciamo a capire che da qualche
parte c'era quel niente che arrivava e
portava via tutto alla mia mamma e
portava via
la mamma da noi bambini molti anni dopo
ho capito che in quel momento ho
cominciato a immaginare un sogno il
sogno era quello di riuscire a tenere a
bada al mostro che arrivava e che
portava via tutta la mia mamma
quel mostro terribile che ogni tanto
faceva capolino e che divideva le due
spazi molto vicini che la felicità e
della disperazione
all'epoca si diceva che la mia mamma
avesse l'esaurimento nervoso soffrisse
ed esaurimenti nervosi
oggi si chiama depressione maggiore ma
il concetto è sempre quello lì e lì ho
cominciato il mio sogno
chi di voi ha un sogno
chi di voi vive il suo sogno ogni giorno
solo le mani ti faccio l'ultima domanda
chi di voi se fosse sicuro al cento per
cento di riuscirlo a realizzare
partirebbe adesso per il proprio sogno
se qualcuno non alza la mano adesso è
perché io non sono stato bravo a
spiegarmi
evidentemente perché col trascorrere
della vita io avevo sempre presente il
mostro
ogni tanto si affacciava in casa nostra
e quindi io avevo un sacco di strumenti
che mi ero creato lo sport le moto lo
studio ester bravo avere amici benissimo
tutto bene
a un certo momento quando avevo 16 anni
si è ammalato mio fratello cominciato
pian pianino poi sempre peggio
stessi problemi della mia mamma può più
gravi e io continuavo a cercare di
tenere a bada al mostro non avevo molte
risorse ne ho trovate alcune più avanti
la programmazione neurolinguistica prima
tra queste è visto che avevo nel
percorso e quesito diverse risorse
ho cominciato a frequentare un
associazione di familiari di persone con
problemi di salute mentale abbiamo
cominciato a unirci insieme per riuscire
a fare delle cose
e a un certo momento abbiamo veramente
osato abbiamo creato un progetto un
progetto per cui siamo andati a cercare
trainer in giro per il mondo
un progetto per il quale bianc reato uno
staff in italia col quale volevamo
lavorare sulle persone che avevano
problematiche importanti di salute
mentale proprio per riuscire a
dimostrare che mostro lo riuscivi sempre
e comunque
a controllare e quel mostro che stava
fuori e dentro ognuno di noi in modi e
modalità diverse aveva una possibilità
di essere gestito via via che vedevo
questo progetto crescere ero citatissimo
sentivo che stavo facendo qualcosa di
straordinario veramente sentivo che
stavo finalmente riscattando tutto il
dolore che avevamo provato per anni
tutta quella cosa che ti prende ti fa
sentire impotente quando di là la gente
piange sbatte le porte si dispera e tu
non puoi fare niente e della lingua
stava realizzando avevamo la casa
avevano le persone avevamo i trainer
avevano i soldi
avevamo tutto stava per partire e io
toccavo il cielo con un dito
peccato che il giorno prima che
iniziasse progetto la trainer in capo di
quel mese mi ha detto tu devi star fuori
però no tu devi stare fuori non ho
nemmeno ancora capito bene perché ma
sono stato buttato fuori dalla parte
operativa del progetto in quel momento
sono precipitato
ero per terra con il mio sogno che si
era infranto tutti i cocci erano intorno
a me ero lì che guardavo i cocci la
possibilità di fare la differenza
sparita progetto andava avanti da solo
se andava avanti
un momento nel quale respirare
profondamente un momento nel quale
chiederti veramente chi sei e cosa stai
facendo poi osservi tutti questi cocci
del tuo sogno
e se non cauterizza troppo le ferite se
non fai finta che vada tutto bene lo
stesso se non ti distrae troppo se non
trovi degli strumenti per dire ok non
importa ma ti dici la verità così come
non ho la possibilità di realizzare la
cosa più importante che volevo
realizzare nella vita quella cosa per la
quale ho sentito a un certo momento
adesso è stato chiamato sul pianeta ma
lo posso fare
mi fai un casino male però non sono
morto
sono vivo e guardando questi cocci
a un certo punto era come se i cocci
fossero diventati dei piccoli semi di
piccoli doni delle cosine che se l'è
pianti le curie le ami possono fiorire
possono diventare qualcosa di ancora più
straordinario uno dei doni meravigliosi
che ho ricevuto e l'ho ricevuto solo
grazie a questo disastro è stato il
fatto che alcuni amici mi si sono
stretti intorno mentre tutti mi
attaccavano anche personalmente dicendo
che ero io il mostro cosa che mi
lasciano un po così e tra queste persone
in particolare una ragazza che poi
sarebbe diventata la mamma delle mie
bambine consentendomi di realizzare un
sogno che ormai temevo di non riuscire a
realizzare nella vita diventare babbo 50
anni non è proprio sempre una cosa che
ti aspetti di riuscire a fare e quindi
questa cosa mi ha fatto capire quanto
nel momento nel quale le persone per
paura che il sogno non si realizzi
non partono per realizzarlo quanto le
persone sprechino un'opportunità immensa
perché in realtà quello che succede è
solo che ho il sogno si realizza
e allora sei felice ho il sogno non si
realizza e va in frantumi
e allora devi guardare bene perché è
vero che c'è il dolore di quello che hai
perso innegabile non volevo che andasse
così
ma è anche vero che lì di fianco al
dolore di quel che hai perso arrivano
questi doni che se sai guardare se sai
accogliere se sei aprirti non sai ancora
quanta meravigliati possano portare le
persone subiscono lutti malattie
incidenti infortuni sono qua dei miei
amici e clienti che la sera anche uso
che lui sia dell'ufficio e la notte è
andato tutto a fuoco la mattina dopo non
ci avevano più la loro azienda fa male
anche lì ci sono dei doni da saper
guardare la saper accogliere spesso la
gente dice non ci voglio neanche pensare
abbiamo dei delle cose che temiamo al
punto che non ci vogliamo neanche
pensare la morte è una di queste no non
ci voglio pensare la malattia un
incidente se succede qualcosa mio figlio
non ci voglio neanche pensare
ecco io credo che invece sia una buona
idea pensarci è una delle cose che amo
fare ogni tanto e prendermi del tempo
mettermi nel mio meglio
sentirmi veramente bene e entrare
profondamente in una di queste
situazioni chiamarlo il mostro dire
arriva qua
facciamo come se mi succedesse la cosa
più terribile che riesco a immaginare
nella vita facciamo che provo a sentirla
sta cosa facciamo che scopro che non
muoio
non solo ma che se sono abbastanza bravo
riesco anche a scoprire come andare
oltre
riesco a chiamare benedizioni quelle che
qualcuno chiama le grandi sfortune della
terra è perché c'è sempre qualcosa di
buono lì ma sta a noi decidere di
vederlo
quindi nel momento nel quale questo ci
capita
siamo pronti abbiamo già creato quel
meccanismo dentro di noi per il quale
qualunque sogno si infranga noi sapremo
come cogliere quei doni sapremo fare
quella cosa piuttosto controversa che è
il prendere il buono da una situazione
terribile abbiamo sentito molte storie
già oggi ancora ne sentiremo terribili
ma quello che ha fatto la differenza non
è quanto è stata terribile il passato ma
quanto è stato usato nel bene il dono di
ciò che ha portato che non vuol dire che
volevo che succedesse ma vuol dire che
visto che è successo io ho preso un
ispirazione ho preso una possibilità ho
colto buono che si era sono riuscito a
trasformarla in qualcosa di
straordinario questo solo se riusciamo a
guardare avanti ea sapere che ce la
possiamo fare
perché io sono convinto veramente che il
futuro appartiene a chi osa sognare
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no